للسيطره على الخوارزميات التي تشغل
التطبيق واشنطن طلبت من مالكي تيك توك في
الصين بيعه اسهمهم او مواجهه خطر حظر
التطبيق الصين بدورها تحاول التهرب من
عمليه البيع عبر سن تشريعات تمنع ربما
تؤخر ما تسعى اليه الولايات المتحده الى
جانب عوائق اخرى تقف امام هذه الخطوه حيث
ان 60% من اسهم بايت دانس الشركه الامه
لتطبيق تيك توك مملوكه للمستثمرين عالميين
في حين ان 20% مملوكه للموظفين وعشرين
بالمئه اخرى لمؤسسها
وعلى الرغم من عدم حاجتها الى المزيد من
راس المال جمعت نحو خمسه مليار دولار
بتقييم قدره 180 مليار دولار لتوسيع
قاعدتها من المساهمين الامريكيين خطوه
تاتي في وقت يتوقع ان يزيد عدد مستخدمي
التطبيق بسبب الحظر الامريكي وبعض البلدان
الاوروبيه